Helia Trion, som jag brukar säga, den följer jag fullt ut.
Jag säger så här, ska du skapa content på en sån plattform så ska du göra en av tre saker.
Du ska utbilda, du ska utmana, eller så ska du underhålla ditt nätverk.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Michella Portgårdon till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Och Michell, du är en van poddare.
Du är en av två personer någonsin som inte har behövt några frågor i förväg.
Ja, nu är man ju det.
Så det känns slaget.
Men ja, superkul att få vara med här.
Ja, gött.
Du har en egen podd egentligen, där du sprider din vishet.
Vad heter podden?
Podden heter Sälj och entreprenörspodden.
Det är ju en live podd då, så den nyttjar lika bra uppstyrd som din.
Så det är en tagning och det är ett sitt.
Men ja, jag delar tips och råd och emellanåt har jag lite gäster också.
Min Accident-podd som jag brukar säga.
Vadå är Accident-podd?
För att den blir till av misstag eller för att det brukar bli misstag när du spelar in dig?
Nej, precis.
Det var faktiskt helt oplanerat.
Jag körde ju sådana här...
LinkedIn hade ju en ljud-evenemang kunde man göra förr, som var liksom en live-podd-grej som de hade.
Det var en funktion.
Man kunde ju göra live-video, men du kunde också göra som en live-podd.
Så testade jag det några gånger och så var det ett gäng som alltid hörde av sig.
Så jag sa, kan man höra på den i efterhand?
Och då trodde jag, jag tog det för givet att det är klart att du måste kunna.
För det kan du ju men om du har kört en video live så ligger den kvar på din profil.
Men det gjorde det inte och då blev det såhär, jag får lägga dig i något podd och så föddes det.
Och sen dess har det bara blivit som det har blivit.
Men därav kommentarerna.
På något sätt så avslöjar jag det lite vad vi ska snacka om idag också.
Jag tänker att vi ska komma in lite på vem du är, men jag hänger lite grann på LinkedIn nu för tiden.
Och LinkedIn har ju förstått att det är det stora säljmäckat för företagstjänster åt alla möjliga håll.
Det finns ganska många, vad ska vi kalla det, självutnämnda experter.
Det finns ganska mycket, kanske lite bullshit, och ganska många som spamar varenda kommentarsfält de hittar.
Jag tänkte att vi skulle försöka navigera det där, men också besvara om man faktiskt kan sälja via LinkedIn, eller om alla bara bemöter dig som en telefonförsäljare och stänger ner så fort de hör att du skriver hej, hur mår du?
Men kan du inte börja lite med att förklara vad du jobbar med eller vad du gör, så att vi får någon sorts bakgrund?
Absolut.
Jag har ju jobbat med att coacha, hjälpa soloprenörer och småföretagare.
De senaste tio åren har jag spenderat på att coacha dem i sälj-
och marknadsprocesser.
Det kom ju ur att jag själv har gjort en resa som både säljare och företagare sen många år, alla år.
Jag har byggt ett antal bolag själv, mycket på lek och bus men också ibland seriöst.
Och så har jag också haft de flesta säljjobben.
Man kan tänka sig alltifrån telefon när man var ung till försäljningsdirektör och jobbade med stora varumärkesprocesser och IT-strukturer.
Men sen 2016 i alla fall så har jag valt det här spåret och det var ju efter en observation att vi pratar, och det gör vi fortfarande inte så mycket, men vi pratade extremt lite om försäljning för en företagare, specifikt.
Och det tyckte jag blev, ja, jag ramlade in ganska hårt i det.
Jag tyckte att det var ganska spännande och jag blir väldigt, vad ska man säga, manisk när jag väl, som alla entreprenörer antagligen, blir i att titta lite på det här med ja, men hur ser det egentligen ut?
Och hur många är det som startar varje år?
Och hur ser överlevnadsgraden ut?
Och ju mer statistik jag läste på, ju mer övertygad var jag om att det här är helt rätt spår.
Sen skulle det ju visa sig att det var sjukt svårt att få det här att rulla, för jag är ju transparent med det också, att det har ju absolut varit den, det har varit den absolut tuffaste resan jag har gjort.
Nu är det roligt, men de första sex-sju åren var det skitjobbigt.
Mycket ekonomisk stress och alla de här grejerna, men det är väl igenom allt det där så känner man ju att det är värt det.
Så att det är vad jag gör idag, jobbar med ett fyrtiotal entreprenörer varje år och ser till att de liksom får ordning på sälj-
och marknadsprocesserna så att de kan börja leva på bolaget på riktigt.
Sen hänger vi bara vidare om de tycker det ska ju man.
Du säger att det fanns inte så mycket sälj för företagare.
Är det då att du menar att alla säljböcker är typ skrivna för säljare som jobbar i en stor organisation, men att man snackar ganska lite om, du driver ett företag som, jag vet inte, du säljer liksom trädbeskärningstjänster och du ska ut och sälja det eller?
Nej men det är jätteintressant fråga.
Precis så var det.
Tittar du på alla säljböcker så är de skrivna för säljare till exempel.
Det jag också såg var att det finns mycket start i eget kurser och alla de här grejerna.
Det var ju när man gick in och tittade såhär, men hur mycket försäljning pratade vi?
Om det var det kanske någon timma här och där och det var oftast ren skit.
Det var av människor som inte kan ge bort vatten i öknen ens.
Så de skulle säga hur man går ut och skapar behov ungefär.
Utifrån det så var det ju att det är jättetydligt.
Vi pratar om allt inför, det vill säga vilken bolagsform och gör din hemsida ungefär och kanske lite paketering men aldrig.
Okej, så när allt är klart, vad gör du måndag morgon?
Det var det ju ingenting.
Och det vet vi ju alla som har varit företagare att gör du inget så får du inget.
Det är den enkla brutala sanningen.
Men det är också det som gör att en annan observation parallellt med det då, för jag insåg att jag går till en målgrupp som hatar sälj, för alla som inte är i sälj hatar sälj, är ju också kanske de värsta krängarna när de väl är på de här nätverksträffarna och sånt där.
De springer fram och liksom hej jag jobbar med det här och du drar sin jävla hisspitch.
Och jag bara det är för dåligt, det måste gå att göra bättre.
Så där var liksom varför då och hur det kom igång.
Jag bara tänker att vi kan komma in lite på strategier eller vad du tänker och sådant, men när du började sälja detta 2016, hur sugna var företagare på att hoppa på den här tjänsten?
Det var ingen lätt pitch.
Din hiss pitch var inte så jävla smidig eller?
Nej men det var den inte.
Det är så mycket jag tänker tillbaka på den.
Jag tänker ofta på den här.
Jag var ju såhär klassisk liksom.
Jag har uppfunnit elden ungefär och nu ska jag frälsa världen.
Jag trodde ju som alla då och noobies att jag blir mottagen med öppna armar och det här kommer att bli bra.
För jag hade ju en idé om att de här företagsorganisationerna därute till, de kommer älska detta tänkte jag.
In kom ju en övertänd spagge med för mycket energi.
Det ska ju sägas att jag har ju träffat dig några gånger i verkligheten eller vad man ska säga.
Vi har ju suttit på samma kontor så vidare.
Men du har ju ganska hög energi.
Du och jag är ju inte på samma våglängd.
Exakt.
Det är så jäkla roligt.
Tänk då hur jag var för tio år sedan.
Du är mogel nu.
Detta är den lugna Michelle jag har träffat.
Detta är den lugna Michelle.
Ja men precis.
Du fattar ju.
Klassiskt då, då så var jag ju, jag pratade om en lösning innan vi ens var överens om problemet.
När jag går tillbaka till mig själv och analyserar, men vad gjorde jag själv för fel?
Ja men jag gjorde ju felet alla andra gör.
Jag var så exalterad i lösningen så jag glömde det här viktiga med att det är ingen idé att pitcha någonting förrän vi är överens om problemet som ska lösas.
Så jag börjar ju fel ändå av repet som alla gör.
Så det var jättesvårt.
Mycket stolpe ut, jag fick mycket silent treatment och droppen var faktiskt när jag jag hade bokat massa möten i Stockholm med de här företagsorganisationerna.
Jag ska inte slänga någon av dem framför bussen nu.
Behövs inte längre.
Men då sitter jag där på tåget och är superladdad och liksom det här kommer bli den bästa dagen ever.
Ferrari låg i inkarien.
I vanukarien liksom.
Nu ska jag vara average.
Nej.
Och jag kommer upp och jag får liksom den här otroligt nonchalanta bemötandet på vissa håll rentav tråkigt bemötande då.
Så jag lämnar Stockholm och jag är så förbannad.
En del av oss behöver ju motivation positivt för att bli vassa.
Jag behöver hamna i det tillståndet.
Okej, I'll show you.
Jag behöver matchen.
Så jag bestämde mig där och då faktiskt att jag gör det här själv.
Så jag släppte organisationen och så började jag gå ut och börja bearbeta marknaden.
Det har varit sjukt många lärdomar för att göra mig bättre och förstå det här med köpbeteenden mycket, mycket mer om man säger vad.
Och hur lite en tjänst eller en produkt egentligen har med säljet att göra.
Det är ganska fascinerande när man bryter ner det.
Vad menar du med det då?
Det är just detta då att som entreprenör så letar vi lösningar på problem därute.
På en eller annan sätt.
Det kan vara en fysisk produkt som ni säljer till exempel eller det kan vara i andra saker, tjänster och så vidare.
Olika koncept och så.
Och grejen är den att, igen då, tillbaka till det här påståendet, det är ingen idé att pitcha förrän vi är överens om problemet som ska lösas.
Det är en jävla bra mening för det jag vet.
Ja, det är det.
Och den säger väldigt mycket om vad det är vi måste göra initialt.
Och det jag menar då när jag säger att produkten har så lite att göra eller tjänster med säljet, det är att själva säljet liksom börjar först när vi är överens återigen om det här problemet.
När vi har samsyn kring att det här är en utmaning för oss.
Det här är någonting som kostar oss, det här är någonting som inte är optimalt för våra verksamhet, bra.
Nu är jag beredd att börja titta på om jag...
Först och främst är jag beredd att vilja lösa det överhuvudtaget.
Och om svaret är ja, då är jag först öppen för att titta på vad finns det för lösningar?
Men lösningen i sig kommer inte att skapa insikt till ett problem.
Det är helt bakvänt hur vi har jobbat med sälj och jag själv i alla år.
Och det är det här som gör det så intressant då, för det spiller över på allting men...
Men det var ju först när jag själv mer och mer pratade om till exempel det här med ekonomisk stress och hur ska vi tackla det.
Det är utifrån företagarnas vardag och de då därifrån kunde se att, aha, jag har de här situationerna men det är försäljning som kommer ta mig ur det.
Bra, nu är jag intresserad av att prata om hur vi kan lösa det.
Men innan det var så var det ju hej att jobba med säljutveckling till den målgruppen.
Det var ju nästan så det kom både biblar och vitlök och kors och grejer flygande.
Det har varit otroligt tufft och lärarvikt men bra.
Nytt och behövligt.
Jag behövde bli bättre innan det var dags.
Men det är lite grann då om din resa eller vad man ska säga.
Nu har du ju gjort, vad ska man säga, du har ju lite olika kanaler, du har ju ett event som ni kör här årligen är det väl, det är inte två gånger per år, det är årligen tror jag.
Och sen så har du den här podden som du kör, du skrev en bok här för ett tag sen och sen har du, vad ska man kalla det, som en sorts kurs eller coaching beroende på vad man hoppar in i.
Det är liksom om dig, men om vi hoppar in på resterande människor därute som ska sälja sina olika tjänster, de säljer kanske inte seri coaching på det sättet.
Som sagt, jag tänker att vi ska gå in lite på LinkedIn, för det har blivit liksom, jag tycker att det har hypats upp att det verkligen är, det här är the shit säljkanal som man ska gå in i.
Sälj folk på LinkedIn, funkar det som kanal?
Nej, inte i den ljussträckningen om det är så.
Nej men det är sådär, det är ju lite buzzword nu nästan att säga det, men jag hävdar att de absolut flesta gör inte det av många skäl.
LinkedIn är ju en konservativ, skulle jag säga, svårflörtad domna som man får ha väldigt mycket tålamod med.
Absolut, för min egna del så är det kanske 95% av mina klienter kommer därifrån, men det har tagit lång tid att bygga den plattformen.
Men LinkedIn, jag brukar säga det, det här är världens största affärsmässa, där det går förbi, där alla har en monteplats.
Och det går förbi hundratusentals människor varje dag.
Men precis som när du går på en affärsmässa då, så finns det montrar som du känner dig välkommen i, det finns montrar som du blir nyfiken på att gå in på, men du har garanterat gått förbi hur många som helst, som du inte ens har lagt märke till.
Ungefär så skulle man kunna summera LinkedIn faktiskt också.
Och är det en bra säljkanal, 100% om man gör rätt.
Men det är långt ifrån alla som hjälper.
Vad är det du har gjort rätt då?
För du sa att 95% av din sälj kommer därifrån.
Vad är det som funkar och vad är det som inte funkar?
Det som inte funkar är ju, igen då då, det är ingen reklamyta.
Här är det så viktigt att förstå.
Jag tittar ju till exempel på vad du gör.
Det du gör framgångsrikt är ju att du du delar din resa, du delar din kunskap, du delar liksom sånt som gör att folk både lär sig någonting men också får lite underhållning men det blir också relevant business-information.
Så du har hittat en bra kombination där i din storytelling.
Jag är rankad tvåa i Sverige idag på LinkedIn när det kommer till försäljning av Fabicon som är en sån här plattform som rankar kreatörer.
Lite kul, kan man gå in och titta.
Och där får man också lite statistik då.
Jag har någonstans...
Vem är det här Aset som ligger rätta som vi måste knicka?
Han har lämnat Sverige, jag har hört, jag vet inte varför.
Då borde han inte röra.
He sleeps with the fishes.
Nej!
Så jävla ofärgad.
Ja, absolut.
Nej, men han är väl duktig.
Nej men då, och det här verktyget då, eller den här, den talade om för mig att jag hade 260 någonting inlägg på ett år.
Av någon anledning fångade jag den siffran för...
Jag brukar svara såhär att, du kan gå in på min profil och du kommer, av de 260 inläggen jag har gjort på ett år, så kan du inte hitta två inlägg där jag pratar om egentligen vad det är jag levererar.
Utan, ja, jag följer den här heliga trion som jag brukar säga.
Den följer jag fullt ut.
Jag säger såhär, ska du skapa content på en sån plattform så ska du göra en av tre saker.
Du ska utbilda, du ska utmana, eller så ska du underhålla ditt nätverk.
Någon av de tre ska dina inlägg göra.
Då vet du att det är bra.
Men inget av det jag sa nu var, pracka på, berätta exakt vad du gör hela tiden, kränga, kränga, kränga, inget av det sa jag.
Utan utbilda, utmana, utmana är ju att utmana och tänka för övrigt.
Att man hjälper målgruppen då då att faktiskt göra en tankeförflyttning.
Och jag tror att där är skillnaden då att man behandlar det som en plattform att låta din kunskap berätta vem du är och vilken nivå du ligger på och inte din produkt återigen för det är helt jäkla ointressant.
Och där är vad jag gör, om man får svara på din fråga.
Ja, till och med i kundmöten ibland kan jag skoja lite med folk och säga det efter det har gått en 40 minuter att du vet fortfarande inte vad jag gör.
Och då trillar jag ofta på lättare ner.
Vilket de förväntar sig, för i mitt fall förväntar man ju så nästan en pitch.
Eftersom jag har rubriken då.
Så det där skulle jag säga.
Det det egentligen handlar om är att bygga en personlighet som man vill följa och när behovet uppstår eller när man börjar bli nyfiken då är man enkel att ta kontakt med eller liksom komma in med.
Är det det som är rätt väg liksom?
Precis, jag vill bara addera det.
Jag pratar ju ofta väl, eller min grej är att jag pratar mycket om det här med mikroförflyttningar, jag kallar det.
Och mikroförflyttning är ju att vi ska förstå att bakom varje köp så finns det först en emotionell process som alla ska gå igenom.
Och när vi pratar försäljning så blir det ofta tvärtom och det är därför vi hamnar i produktspåret och inte i den mentale, emotionella resan som vi behöver göra.
Och när jag säger emotionellt så menar jag att vi ska sitta och böla med varandra, utan någonstans är det det här att 1.
vi behöver lite distans.
Den svenska modellen är som man skojade under covid, vi behöver inte att staten säger två meter, vi har två meter.
Och en försiktig approach är att jag kan släppa in det i mitt nätverk men det betyder inte att vi är redo att göra affär.
Om jag då successivt är duktig på att dela relevant information till mitt nätverk, att jag kan vara generös med min kunskap, generös med mina erfarenheter, utmana dem att tänka, då blir det så här att, för min målgrupp har ju ett omedvetet behov av sina tjänster.
Och för det är väldigt lätt att också ramla in i det att vi tror att det handlar bara om de som redan har ett medvetet behov, de som redan har börjat komma igång i den tanke, men det är ju bara toppen av isberget.
För alla bolag har egentligen en absolut största massan med det omedvetna behovet.
Och det är de som inte funkar att bara säga hej och ha det här.
Utan då kan mitt content hjälpa till med att skapa lite insikt, få en tanke med att aha det är fan det där jag inte har tänkt på, till att aha, till att jassa, till att fan det där var intressant.
Och så börjar de här sakta men säkert ske.
Och det gör att vi bara kommer närmare och närmare och till slut så börjar relevanta människor interagera på något sätt då.
Och det är därifrån och framåt som det börjar bli intressant med en vidare dialog.
Men det kräver lite tålamod att göra det.
Du har ju en rätt god dialekt.
Har du den för att vara approachable eller är det något du har lagt dig till med?
Eller låter du så på riktigt?
Ja, precis.
Nej, jag låter så här.
Det är så roligt för i min bransch ska man ju helst tjäna det krisen.
Hur läge?
Ja men du vet du ska bara lyfta luren man.
Jag spyr på det här.
Har du några kunder från Stockholm?
Massor.
Ja, jag har kunder över hela Sverige idag.
Men nej men det är väl lite det att, jag har ju uppväxt här, jag kom till Sverige som barn men uppväxt i staden och då blev det lite extra.
Sen av någon annan blev det ännu värre när jag åk i ett stock.
Ja, jag fattar.
Jag har ju dig på LinkedIn och ibland är ju du lite personlig eller du har ju lite åsikter.
Du är ju inte helt tyst hela tiden, eller vad jag ska uttrycka.
Det är inte bara affärsmässiga diskussioner alltid.
Vart går gränsen?
Alltså, detta är ju inte Twitter eller X liksom.
Hur långt ska man vara personlig innan det börjar bli liksom, i alla fall, det där är en jobbig jävel.
Nej men jag tror att var och en får liksom rannsaka det lite.
Jag har ju, att jag är det idag lite mer är nog en självförtroende fråga.
Hade man tittat på vad jag postade när jag började min LinkedIn-väg, så var jag otroligt försiktig.
Alltså jag var så försiktig så att det, det var, det är ju löjligt liksom.
Men i takt med att jag känner själv att, ja men, folk vet vem jag är, de har liksom lätt känna mig, så är det klart att jag känner också att, ja men jag kan vara, kan vara mig själv.
Nu är jag ju en person som, även privat är jag ju väldigt så här, att jag har starka, jag står för vad jag tycker, även om det inte alltid faller i god jord, så men, och jag tror att så länge man inte går till, alltså jag är noga med att det får inte komma liksom tre, fyra inlägg på raken som blir överpersongliga, men om det på något sätt kommer någon gång och det blir personligt men inte privat, det tror jag är en bra tumregel då, att vi får gärna vara lite personligt, för jag tror att det finns en fara i att vi blir för, folk vill göra affärer med människan bakom bolaget i väldigt många fall idag.
Sverige är ett småföretagarland, det glömmer vi ofta, men det är liksom 1% som är 100 anställda och uppåt, av närmare 1,2 miljoner företag.
Så att de absolut flesta vill ha den där personen.
Och jag tror att kan man bara hitta en bra att vara personlig emellanåt men inte för privat?
Är det någonting till exempel, jag som ändå är mycket i sociala medier, du hittar aldrig bilder på mina barn, du hittar knappt någon bild på min fru.
Så jag har mina gränser liksom.
Jag kan prata om vissa saker men that's it.
Alltså när jag skriver om, nu skrev jag för någon månad sedan om att jag skulle byta lager.
Jag vet liksom, vissa inlägg när jag lägger upp, så vet jag att jag kommer få inom liksom 2 timmar 20 säljare som hör av sig i DMS.
Jag tycker att det är en kass strategi liksom, men folk gör ju så, alltså måste det ju uppenbarligen funka på något sätt, eller vad är liksom approachen bakom hela, funkar det och när funkar det och hur gör man för att få det att funka eller är det bara skit rakt igenom?
Nej, jag säger ju såhär att nej, det funkar inte.
Jag menar, den approachen är inte bättre än ett cold call, att någon ringer dig och säger hej.
Och sen finns det ju alltid undantag på sånt där, för det finns alltid någon det funkar för, som de här bolagen pekar på och säger men kolla, det här funkar för den.
Ja visst, man kan ju också säga att man kan bli rik på kasinot, men det är en jävligt dömd plan att planera efter det menar jag.
Men förlåt, jag bara avbryter, jag vet det, men alla kan inte bygga upp en personlighet som liksom delar massa utmaningar och tanker.
Alltså det ligger inte för en stor del av befolkningen.
Det gör det inte men...
Vad fan ska de göra då?
Det man kan göra, det finns lite olika, men i grund och botten så kan alla, jag brukar prata om det att vi behöver liksom idag, jag tror att var och en behöver det, vi behöver en digital identitet.
Och vi behöver liksom släppa det här med att jag ska ha, för det handlar inte om att du ska ha ett nätverk på 100.000 personer, eller att du måste nå en miljon människor.
Du kan ha ett nätverk på LinkedIn med 200 personer, och du kan absolut bygga en digital närvaro med det.
Återigen, om vi behandlar det som monterytan på världens största affärsmässa, så kan vi lite då och då bestämma oss för att vara lite inbjudande till den monterytan.
För felet vi gör är ju att vi springer runt och haffar folk i den här mässan och säger, du, kom till min monter, här ska jag visa dig.
Och så börjar folk brotta ner varandra för att komma dit.
Det är ju det vi inte tål.
Jag kan dela vad som händer i min vardag.
Jag kan dela grejer som jag har hjälpt mina kunder med.
Jag kan dela sådana saker som gör att mina presumtiva kunder ser en kontext som de kan relatera till.
Då är det ju såhär att vi gillar ju...
Sverige är ju buzzword-himlen skulle jag säga.
En av de grejerna som vi alltid har sagt i decennier är ju om en affär är relationer.
Och jag brukar säga det.
Det är ungefär som att du går ut och säger till en grupp människor är det viktigt att äta nyttig mat?
Ja, säger alla.
Men de gör det inte.
Och ungefär så är det med relationer också.
För de flesta vet inte vad det innebär.
Relationer tar lite tid.
Och jag tror att största felet överlag när vi pratar om allt sånt här är att vi har återigen inte tålamod i våra processer.
För när man säger att det inte funkar så bygger det på min motfråga i okej, vad pratar vi för tidslinjer då?
För jag vet, och det här har jag ju testat på alla möjliga branscher du kan tänka dig.
Och jag ser att det fungerar.
Och jag brukar säga det att det här är ingenting som om du behöver göra affärer på en vecka då är det inte lägre att tro att du kan gå ut och spämma folk på LinkedIn och börja skicka offerter i deras inkorgar och så vidare.
Det här är en långsam process som, beroende på vad du har för position, beroende på vad du har för verksamhet och så vidare, så finns det en tidslinje där.
Och gör du bara rätt saker över en viss tid så kommer du att ha nätverkat med rätt människor.
Du kommer att ha gjort relevanta inspel hos rätt människor så att de på något sätt vet vem du är.
Du kommer också automatiskt med det, har fått igång några dialoger.
Så att även om du är det mest, vad ska man säga, osociala, whatever liksom, så kommer du på sikt att få igång dialoger.
Jag har faktiskt aldrig ställt dig frågan insåg jag nu, men jag vågar ju betta min arm på att det har hänt lite för dig via LinkedIn.
Jojo, det har du ju gjort såklart.
Och du och jag är ju, jag menar när man träffar dig och mig, så är ju vi motsatser i personlighet.
Men du har ändå fått dig att funka på linkan också.
Jag tänkte säga, folk tror ju ganska ofta att jag är en social, trevlig människa, för att jag orkar ju liksom vara det 30 minuter om dagen när jag pratar såhär, men på det kontorshotellet som vi satt, så jag kan ju inte namnet på en enda person där, och det är ju ingen som hälsar det på mig på morgonen.
Däremot så har ju du en annan approach när du kommer in där.
Man hör ju liksom det och jag är ju relativt ointresserad av människor i 99 procent av tiden.
Min fru stjäller alltid ut mig.
Hon är såhär, om vi ska gå och hälsa på folk så är hon såhär ja nu säger du hej idag.
Ja jag ska säga hej.
Det är inte så att jag är sur, jag bara, jag lever ju i min egna lilla värld och tänker på liksom ja golvmattor, tycker jag är kul att tänka på.
Men hej, jag är ju sjukt tråkig i 99 procent av tiden så är det ju liksom.
Men absolut, jo jo, alltså jag köper det.
Jag fattar vad du menar liksom, jag fattar er.
Min fördel är ju att vi har liksom annonser och ett nätverk som drar igång utanför min värld, men om man nu tillhör den här lite osociala sidan eller den som inte är naturligt extravärt eller liknande, då kan det ju kännas ganska manipulativt.
Jag tror att man lätt framstår som lite manipulativ om man inte slappnar av i det.
Hur fan ska man komma ifrån det där och bara vara god?
Ja, det är ju lite det då.
Man måste börja från den där man är.
Om man säger då att du aldrig postar och du ska sätta igång med en ligg din-strategi till exempel, då är det inte rimligt att du ska börja göra 10 inlägg i veckan och göra videos och alla de här grejerna.
Det är lika orimligt som att om du är helt ur form så ska du bara gå till gymmet 10 dagar i veckan och ställa upp på Göteborgsvarvet två dagar senare.
Så man måste börja, man behöver ha en plan.
Man behöver liksom igen då.
Jag menar, min vanligaste fråga är hur många har en riktig strategi för LinkedIn idag?
Och de flesta kan inte räcka upp handen där liksom.
Så det gäller att liksom titta på vad har jag för förutsättningar?
Hur ser min bransch ut?
Hur är kotymen i min industri?
Det är ju nästa pilsner.
Vad ska jag tänka på?
Jag menar när jag började med detta, det sista jag ville, det var ju att bli, hamna i facket och här kommer det en säljare.
Så därför att jag har haft extremt tålamod.
Jag får ju vara ännu mer försiktig.
Och därav att jag kan garva lite åt den att du kan kolla alla mina inlägg, du kommer inte att hitta ett enda inlägg där jag beskriver vad jag gör.
Jag gör det typ en gång om året om jag har uppdaterat en broschyr typ.
That's it.
Men varför, är inte det lite korkat eller?
Behövs det inte.
För folk köper, här är ju jättebra fråga, folk köper kunskap ändå.
Alltså köper, det är ju inte så att någon kommer köpa min, man kan, man får inte ens det, köpa min coachning bara sådär.
Utan det kommer ändå att ske ett samtal.
Men tröskeln till det samtalet, går genom att jag har delat någonting i en context som har fått folk att tänka, ah, det där kunde ju vart ja.
Michelle jag vill prata med dig om detta.
Och så börjar den dialogen därifrån, och så kommer produkttjänsten långt här borta sen, för det är då den är intressant.
Sällan, windowshoppar vi tjänster och produkter, ska man lägga ett antal, 10 tusentals kronor och så vidare, det sker ju inte på ett DM eller på att liksom windowshoppa det, utan det kommer ändå vara lite back and forth.
Så det man ska förstå är ju att om man behandlar LinkedIn som att här ska jag få en ordemottagning, då är du rökt.
Behandlar du LinkedIn med att jag ska få igång dialoger och på riktigt bygga förtroendekapital, som sen får bli någonting annat, då får man fart på det.
Och då spelar det ingen roll om du är värt åt vilket håll du vill.
Jag har ju dagar när jag spyr på det.
Det har jag ju också varit transparent med liksom.
Och då har jag mina strategier för att upprätthålla det ändå.
Men återigen, de köper kunskapen.
Det är där det kommer att hända.
Där bygger vi förtroendet och när förtroendet är på plats, då kan vi tänka oss att ta nästa steg, regardless vad det handlar om.
Lite på det spyrtemat, en weird uppföljning på det.
Men liksom, jag jobbade som viktminskningscoach, kanske man ska kalla det, under några år.
Och jag kände liksom år tre att jag sa samma jävla saker i varenda samtal.
Jag hade liksom ingen, jag hade ingen kärlek kvar i mina samtal.
Det blev nästan en automatisk process.
Du har ju ändå coachat ett antal människor och suttit där.
Upplever du aldrig att du blir automatiserad och tappar lite intresse?
Hur motverkar du det då?
För det är inte så jävla bra.
Nej men det har faktiskt hjälpt mig att forma tjänsten som jag gör idag.
För mitt program är ju byggt på både one to one så här, men också en del är ju e-kurser och att man ska ta sig igenom ett visst program då.
Det var där jag fick så här för jag kände att jag stått och dratt det här.
Så när jag sitter i mina one to one till exempel, då pratar vi ju om andra saker, allt runt omkring då.
Och så har jag det generiska om man säger.
Det ligger där, då kan jag säga det bra.
Nästa är att du tittar på den filmen, gör de uppgifterna, så slipper jag säga de bitarna.
För det var där jag kräkte, står det första gången.
Men jag köper det, för det var fan vad jag tröttnade till slut.
Jag tyckte jag sa samma mening.
Och till slut visste man nästan vilket manus man skulle följa.
Och så sa man, här kommer jag få mothugg, men då säger jag detta och då kommer de säga så, men nio av tio funkar.
För en av tio kommer bli skitsur att säga upp detta.
Man blev nästan cynisk i hela sin, men spännande, jag tycker det är intressant.
Hur gör du för att hålla dig jour, liksom när man är en säljare så känns det som att man kanske lite lätt fastnar i vad man tycker stämmer.
Jag tänker att det finns lite olika säljskolor, eller lite olika inriktningar.
Hur gör man, vilka följer du eller vilka, hur gör du för att hålla huvudet öppet eller skiter du bara i det?
Du har hittat din grej liksom.
Nej, men det är en jättebra fråga också.
Dels, det är flera delar.
Nummer ett, både du och jag är kampsportare och jag tror att jag bara har det i mig att aldrig tro att jag är klar.
Det har bidragit väldigt mycket till den här resan.
Jag är ju tio gånger bättre idag än vad jag var för tio år sedan.
Och jag kommer vara tio gånger bättre om tio år än vad jag är idag.
Jag lär mig dels otroligt mycket genom mina klienter, faktiskt.
För det är ju allt ifrån jurister till arkitekter till you name it, liksom.
Och det är otroligt utvecklande att jobba med det.
Sen omger jag mig i en väldigt liten cirkel, men en vetgirig cirkel i sig, så att vi tipsar varandra emellanåt och lite hit och dit.
Sen är det väl också lite att det är klart att i mina algoritmer dyker det upp.
Jag har två saker som dyker upp.
Det är antingen matlagning eller så är det någon form av tips och råd inom personlig utveckling eller försäljning eller psykologi eller någonting.
Jag plockar mycket russin upp kakan hela tiden.
Och sen absolut, det som håller mig på tårna, det är ju att jag har bestämt mig för att det här området som jag har ringat in, det ska jag dominera.
Det ska liksom, om du ens funderar på att konkurrera med mig här, eller drömmer om det, så är det bäst att du vaknar och ber om ursäkt liksom, som man medallisar.
Och det har jag en väldig pride i också.
Så jag hävdar ju med bestämdhet att ingen har det området så starkt som jag har idag.
Och det är ju på grund av att jag hela tiden också vill förnya och jobba med det.
Och det är också ett sätt att inte tröttna på det.
För jag skulle nog tröttnat för länge sen om jag hade samma tugg.
Och det är inte ens seriöst.
Om jag jobbar med sälj och marknad och jag år ut och år in låter likadan i en värld som är en verklighet på måndag och det kan på fredag vara något helt annat inom de här två delarna.
Det är bara oseriöst.
Så jag kan vara ganska rak emellanåt om gamla skola så jag vet att du har sett mig men har du gamla klipp och sådant som ligger kvar på er själv?
Ja, det är så punsamt.
Känner du cringe när du ser det?
Ja, jag har en video och du vet bara prata om den så dör jag.
Fy fan, punsamt.
Men de har kvar den för att ständigt påminna mig.
Hur jävla, aaah.
Och det var faktiskt, jag skäms jävligt.
Jag kommer aldrig att glömma, 14 januari 2014 så gör jag en, film i datum, aah, smärta.
Därför du vet, det är ett satsa i fast.
Så gör jag nämligen en promo video uppe på min, jag bodde centralt i stan innan och då bodde jag på Stampgatan, hade en takterrasmåning.
Så står jag och filmar.
Och så säger jag, jag vet inte varför kommer jag redan lycklig.
Jag gör ju en promo om ett affärs-
event som jag har bestämt mig för att göra i källorna.
Jag står ju och gör denna och vet att jag är luspunk, jag har absolut inga kontakter där för att göra det.
Ja du vet, alla de här grejerna.
Men jag gör ju en sån där riktig cringe-promo.
Ja du vet.
Men jag sa att jag skulle komma i mars och 6 juni 2015, då har jag det här affärs-eventet.
Så det var en annan story.
Men jag har en hel del material där det bara är omg.
Jag har också faktiskt sånt som ligger på YouTube som är, du vet, någon gammal sån här highlight som jag klippte ihop från när jag körde mission wrestling.
Och det är liksom, och så ligger man liksom och kramas.
Och om någon skulle titta på det så är det såhär, vad fan gör han till?
Och så har jag lagt till någon musik i bakgrunden, och så är det, jag kommer inte ihåg vad det står, jag minns inte men så har man säkert skrivit någon cool titel.
Ja, utmanar Sverige i liten och så är det liksom jag och två polare.
Det finns ingen levande man du är rädd för.
Åh fy fan.
Ska vi sluta där innan vi ballar ur eller?
Vi ballar ur helt.
Vi tar resten off cam.
Stort tack för att vara med Michelle.
Fan vad seriöst du kan vara.
Det var väldigt trevligt.
Jag ska säga tack så mycket och tack.
Tack själv.
Tack för att jag fick vara med här och vi ses.
När jag körde mission wrestling.
Och det är liksom, jag ligger och...
Och så ligger man liksom och kramas.
Och om någon skulle titta på det så är det såhär, vad fan gör han till?
Och så har jag lagt till någon musik.